funny you should mention Zack Ned you
probably have great sex with his wife
the try guys have a new show called
squad Wars where celebrity squads face
off against each other we just kind of
assume that we're good squad we've never
actually proved it so we're gonna take a
genetic compatibility test to see if we
actually truly are the ultimate squad I
can say with confidence that we are not
I don't need to spit in a vial to find
that out look at your genetic
composition and how it affects your
neuro chemistry and then we can actually
predict who's gonna be a good love
relationship who's gonna be a good
bromance because we look at your genes
are we gonna find out if Zack and I are
close friends or if maybe Eugene and I
should have sex what do we find out here
yeah I can tell you
we had to notice this look under a
microscope so we could figure out your
brain chemistry you look at genes like
oxytocin dopamine and we give a
psychological profile test as well
because relationships aren't just about
your pure neuro chemistry you're born a
certain way biologically but then you
raise a certain way that also shapes
your personality so instant chemistry
needs two things from you first we need
you to take a very detailed
psychological test time to take a test
to find out who's actually my friend so
these are all questions of if your
relationship I'm gonna answer them
thinking about my wife which will just
be great you're sitting together with
your partner watching a movie on TV you
enjoy reaching out and touching oh
really getting into this quick obviously
almost serene yeah that concept loves to
cuddle absolutely work hang out touch
him you get sweaty you got tangled your
arm falls asleep I'll say possibly you
your partner have taken a long weekend
together at a nearby resort just we're
rich now you probably step up and speak
to the management in an effort to
upgrade I would love for somebody else
to handle confrontation if it's a resort
you came like almost certainly yeah not
doing it right if you're not getting
free stuff possibly I'm done you the
results of my psychological profile one
of the things we looked at is who is
more of an alpha male and who is more of
a submissive to alpha males don't do
well together they're competing with
each other so much and they don't get
stuff done if I had to ask the four of
you to pick just one person who you
think would be your best friend if you
were stuck on a desert island for a
weekend who would it be with Ned won't
cooperate with me but together we will
get the most stuff done Keith would get
along the nicest okay interesting and
who would you choose yeah what else at
choose Keith Zach would find like issues
how it gets so frustrated so we're gonna
reveal to
Eugene and Ned come out the highest
alpha males and Keith and Zach come out
as submissive and generally some ISM
males get a lot of alphas very very well
Eugene even though you said that if you
were stuck on a desert island it was Ned
that you'd want to be with the truth is
you guys wouldn't survive because you
get nothing done another part of the
psychology test is intimacy you need to
be open honest and vulnerable right so
what I found is three of you are really
predisposed to be able to have intimacy
very easily emotional intimacy I wonder
who that fourth person is who do you
think that fourth could be who's a
little more reserved what I learned
about your psychological profile you
actually really crave closeness and you
desire intimacy but you're really
reserved and afraid to open up no no
just want us to love you three of you
are also really completely social
animals you love social activity you
love social interactions you're open
you're out there you want to engage with
other people one of you is a little like
that but really really values time alone
I like one day where I don't have to
talk to people I hate being alone I also
don't like the on it actually came out
your genes so social to a point but
really value your alone time it really
matters Zack maybe you're just alone on
Sunday
by default the other thing we look at
when we look at you psychologically is
we look at your ability to be social and
care about each other's feelings as
you're doing stuff and again three of
you highly value cooperation and social
harmony but one of you kind of forceful
and aggressive desires not to please
other people but prefers to lead and not
afraid of confrontation you said I think
I'd prefer him on the desert island
except he'd frustrate me too much right
so you're not caring too much about
other people's feelings because you're
so frustrated and you just want to lead
and go forward whereas the others are
more concerned with social harmony so
even if their idea is not the best way
or they might take it it's not the best
idea why are we doing it exactly yeah
and your color red in your face we are
just having the best of times what's
next and let's start to look at your
neuro chemistry from a biological level
we need you to spit into a test tube
we're going to spit in a tube for
science this is a lot of instructions
for spending a to of a collection of
human DNA he's going the government has
a scientist please look away okay so I'm
gonna spit until it gets to this line
and mist with my liquid seems to be a
recurring theme for me thank you so much
oh that's way too much no we're just
gonna take a little bit back apparently
I have a very wet mouth put this in
until it clicks real loud we're in it
just added the science I go to my spit
it's blue now I wonder what this is
you know I shake it for five seconds one
two three even six or
smells like science now we're gonna send
it off to a lab and see who are the most
compatible with first gene we look at is
oxytocin the bonding hormone we're
looking at who's a thinker and who's a
listener what listeners are really good
at is interpreting emotions whereas the
thinkers are better at decisive action
discharge into the breech don't give a
[ __ ] and we found out that two of you
are thinkers and two of you our
listeners netting Keith the thinkers
Eugene and Zack the listeners make sense
and Eugene and Zack probably think that
these guys aren't listening to you we
think we're good listeners but we're
actually not no you are actually
listening to them we've heard your
argument for the last hour and we're
tired of it I'm very conflicted I just
want to find love here so the next gene
we want to look at is the dopamine
receptor d4 and it has to do with
motivation attention learning and I
found something really interesting in
your guys's genetic profile here the
seven r+ gene only makes up less than
30% of the population highly represented
in CEOs and high-ranking executives Ned
Keith and Zack all have the Explorer 7
our class dopamine gene where rare your
rare
not because we're white straight males
though no we didn't look at the genes
surrounding race we're a minority white
straight men being CEOs crazy I think
you're a good balance to all of them
because it makes you very judicious and
very prudent and more careful these guys
are gonna more likely charge for where
you go whoa whoa whoa we get kill doing
that you are always the person right
before we shoot to be like is this the
best way we can do this because you're
surrounded by another alpha male
actually Ned that's making it be a
little more dominant than you normally
would or that's normally comfortable to
you yeah because genetically that's not
how you're wired grew up with two alpha
sisters and I was always the judicious
one sometimes the running dogs might get
bit we also looked at another kind of
dopamine gee look at the warrior the
fighter right versus the warrior so the
warrior tends to be highly highly
creative but really lousy at
multitasking
the warrior a hard time dealing with
anxiety gets more pleasure out of life
so what do you think you guys land gosh
I think I'm really creative and I worry
all the time generally when I work on a
project nothing else matters warrior
sounds cooler so certainly we all want
to be that one warriors have more
enjoyment in life we evenly divided -
and - vase - do you all have the same
riders warrior yeah
you guys are all lousy lousy
multitaskers that's why we have four try
guys yeah the next gene is my absolute
favorite this test can actually predict
hot passionate sex that will last a
really long time so listen to this back
in our anthropological past when you are
out mating in the environment you wanted
to find somebody who had a very
different immune system than you because
when two people mate they might take
brown eyes from one longlegs from
another or eyesight from one etcetera
except immune systems they actually
combine and make a stronger human being
there's been some research in same-sex
platonic friendships that show that you
want immune systems to be similar so you
smell like each other's brothers yeah
that'd be distracting if I'm always
trying to [ __ ] that yeah yes it would be
next funny you should mention Zak Ned
eighty percent similarity in your immune
systems
your wife would probably be super
attracted to me at least for sex yes
you'd probably have great sex with his
wife
yeah it was about hot sex I want to
choose the most disparate or different
immune systems and that would be YouTube
so we would [ __ ] each other like har
there is a lot of sexual tension here he
denies it that's only a more proof
looking at all of the genes looking at
your psychological test I can tell you
who the most compatible are and who the
absolute least compatible are least
compatible are not surprisingly sitting
the furthest away from each other net in
Eugene is it because we're both too
dominant yes and your relationship could
actually benefit from the two of you
softening your need for dominance the
[ __ ] up there are two people here who
are most compatible I think I'm the most
compatible with Zack Keith and I are
actually in love Keith and I are mostly
better when it comes to sociability in
fact kind of a boy though what a good
guy in it is that can I have already
given up on humanity [ __ ] the hell out
of net the most compatible couple here
could have a long
long healthy happy relationship and we
could predict with more than 80%
reliability that you'll be friends for
years and years and years net is AK
degree of compatibility we see
psychologically we only see usually in
really long term married couples Tom
Ned's wife now
I guess I'm right I am the dead body on
the island you're the one that keeps us
together you don't have an extreme to
make it a match with anybody you just
get along with everybody they all think
I'm their best friend biology is not
destiny neither is psychology it is the
interaction of both and remember our
biggest environment that affects our
biology are our close relationships so
you're saying even though the genetics
tell us we should be compatible with one
person we can choose to all be friends
anyway don't try and force collusive hey
thanks for watching this video if you
liked this and are hungry for more check
out squad wars you can get it for 30
days for free this week net and I join
up with two squads has become
professional wrestlers and we almost
died
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all I learn today is that Zack secretly
wants Ned's wife that wasn't the
takeaway for me